Hello, greetings. Welcome back. We're in
the third discussion on chapter 4.
So, we will look at the questions where
a couple were submitted and people had
written some thoughts.
We can look more at the second half of
the chapter. We can return to the
concepts map
also at the um Frasier has added some
good points
in the fundamentals
uh
repo
which is
there. This is what it looks like when
you run it on your own computer or open
it locally. So here we are in chapter 4.
And then also I have added several
extras. So these are just we we can we
can have the extras may be vastly larger
than the others but things like the KL
divergence.
So different topics that come up,
we can just continue to have many many
many
extras to get at these different topics.
So people can bring up here or in
questions or GitHub issues or whatever
for different topics. And then we'll
keep the chapter
examples
pretty closely tied to the exact
examples in the textbook.
And then we'll have all this extra space
to explore
just more general topics that happen
outside of the textbook.
Lucas wrote, "I find it helpful to go
through the examples with a debugger in
VS Code,
like looking procedurally
kind of operation by operation what what
the
what the code does.
Yes,
it's it's it's always very interesting
to look at uh for example, we talked
about expectation maximization and and
like kind of understand the the even for
a given formalism,
how there's an infinite number of code
implementations, different languages,
different styles, different logging,
configurability,
all these different kinds of things. And
then there's something very fascinating
about taking an equation which is kind
of simultaneous
in its
presentation even if it has like a time
series element and then
taking that to like well how does that
get
ultimately brought down into a
sequential series of instructions to a
CPU?
So what what are the loops and the logic
and that's cool.
All right. And
yeah, I think Frasier has created some
using manm which is the uh three blue
one brown
animation
open source package.
He's made some
some visualizations.
So, if you need memes to share in the
group chat
and just the regular screenshots of the
textbook aren't cutting it,
that's where you that's where you drop
these animations in.
Okay. So, we'll look at we'll return to
the concept map, look at these
questions,
see what else comes up. But if anybody
has another thing they want to discuss,
just raise your hand or write it in the
questions
or put it in the chat.
Okay,
let's just kind of re reset with looking
at the concept map of four.
Okay. So
overall we're dealing with this question
of how do we estimate the posterior?
Posterior is after the observation.
How do you get the prior is a separate
question. But when we collide the prior
with our observation we yield a
posterior. And there are situations
where you can compute that exactly which
is this branch on the right which gives
you precisely
how surprising was that observation
and what's referred to sometimes as
basian surprise. How much did you update
between the prior distribution belief
and the posterior distribution belief.
So if you can compute it exactly, you
have that branch which gives you exactly
the surprisal
and in situations which is going to come
up in a question that was written there.
Um in situations where approximate uh
methods are preferred rather whether
from scaling and computational
intractability
or the sort of ill-behaved or
illspecified or unspecified
true generative distribution. We have
this variational method that's explored
in this chapter.
Variational free energy is shown with a
few different
forms
and decompositions through rearrangement
in 44
and through essentially the Jensen's
inequality variational free energy has
this bounding relationship on surprisal.
So if you push the bound down, you push
what it is bounding down.
Then these uh this left branch 45 is a
bit more fundamentals and background
ideas related to variational calculus
and the fundamental theorem.
And then this four five bottom branch
here has to do with when you're
exploring a joint distribution.
So that could be the joint distribution
of two
covarying
variables out in the world like
temperature and humidity or it could be
um a joint distribution of
observations internal states like a
effect or things like that and action
states. So as sort of foreshadowed and
signaled even though we haven't gotten
there in the book
that's how action is going to be brought
into play is by control or policy
selection as inference aka active
inference where posterior density
estimation isn't just going to be about
perception. That's the traditional sort
of inbound signal processing sense of
posterior density estimation. You have
some priors about what's out there in
the world, some sparse or noisy
observation comes in, you update your
beliefs, and that's your
state-of-the-art belief about what's out
in the world. And then for that outbound
direction, some other policy selection
technique like reward or reinforcement
learning is used. And we're going to be
able to have this unified approach to
perception, cognition, and action. by
treating all of them as part of a joint
distributions posterior density
estimation.
Let's look at well first to that
bounding topic let's look at Frasier's
animation for Jensen's inequality.
Okay, here we go.
Okay,
natural log of x.
So the x
value is just going to be something that
that we control. That's like the
independent variable. And then the
y-axis is going to be the function's
evaluated value at that chosen x value,
which is the dependent variable because
it depends on the independent variable.
And then like there's a ton of stuff to
say about the
natural log specifically and about um
logs overall. But something important to
recognize is that it intersects the
x-axis at one.
Which means that when we flip it, it's
going to similarly asmtote at positive
infinity as x gets tiny rather than
negative infinity.
But it's still going to intersect and
come through at one, which is going to
be very critical for probability, which
is basically all carried out on the 0ero
to one interval, which is like
equivalent to saying something must
happen. So if something has a
probability of 100, we should be
unsurprised when it happens. If
something has a probability of 0.1,
we should be extremely surprised with it
occurring, which is why we use the
negative log as a measure of surprisal,
which is basically Shannon entropy. So
this isn't at like a narrative level or
a psychological level, but at a purely
like next symbol prediction in a string
of letters or symbols, which is kind of
where Shannon was formalizing entropy.
That's that relationship between like
symbol variability
and surprise
as basically this natural log or just
log base whatever it is. Okay.
So the and and Jensen's inequality is
going to hold for all x values not just
on the 0ero to one interval. And then
thank you Andrew. We'll look at that
slide too. Okay. So we have two x
values.
They could be both within the 0ero to
one interval or they could be at any
point.
So we have x1 and x2. And then each of
them have their evaluated natural log
level.
Then there's fancy e which is the
expectation.
Expectation is used in two overlapping
ways sometimes. Sometimes expectation is
used in a
a prospective fashion like what do we
expect the weather to be tomorrow. So
expectation is like anticipation
as there's a common everyday usage
whereas in statistics expectation is
basically the average value of a
distribution. Now those two can be the
same thing like the average value of a
die of a die roll is 3.5.
So what do we expect for the next die
roll? You could say 3.5 but it will
never happen. But you could say like
that um for for some distribution where
that would make sense like our next draw
from this random variable we expect the
expected value. But fancy E is talking
about the mean
not about the next time step. But again
those could be the same thing in a
timebased prediction situation. Okay. So
we have expectation of x which is just
x1 + x2 / 2. It's just the average of
those two numbers on the x-axis alone.
And then because
the log function
is always
with a slope coming up
but the increase of the slope is always
slowing down.
This is the Jensen's inequality
which is that the
log of the expectation
is higher than the expectation of the
log.
And so that's why they bound each other.
But we'll we'll return to it.
How do I Okay. Okay.
And then let's look at Andrew. Want to
describe?
>> Sure. Sure. And we don't have to spend
too much time on it. It's just the very
last slide that I added. And uh I mean
there's there's quite a bit going on
there. Um and uh the big thing is that
um uh with Jensen's inequality, it's
like it's not just that this applies to
the properties of like where and when we
apply logarithms and expectations, but a
variety of other functions. Um and so it
can it can come off as a bit confusing.
Uh and so the the way that the the
equation is reported in the the
textbook, it claims that the expectation
of a function of x is greater than or
equal to the function of an expectation
of x, which kind of looks reversed from
what Daniel was just saying. It looks
like the expectation of here, if we
consider the function to be a log, it
would be saying the expectation of a log
of x is greater than or equal to rather
than the other way around. um that has
to do with the fact that these are um uh
Jensen's inequality kind of the the sign
sort of flips of what's greater than or
less than something else uh based on if
the the underlying function is concave
or convex. So in this case the logarithm
is concave. So it's actually uh reversed
from the way that Sunie first presents
this and that I that might clarify that
conclusion. So it was really just trying
to kind of parse out like very precisely
why does this work? But we still end up
arriving at the same exact thing that
Daniel was going over which is like in
the case specifically of logs for
Jensen's inequality is that the log of
the expectation uh is greater than or
equal to the expectation of the log
rather than the the other way around. So
I was just kind of trying to break down
like one to one like how do we get from
here's an abstract mathematical
principle about Jensen's inequality. How
do we get from there to like variational
free energy and actually you know make
that more concrete with respect to the
textbook and what we're actually
interested in here. Um that that's
essentially it. And for anyone else who
hasn't seen these slides yet I've been
slowly adding slides that just kind of
hyperfocus on particular concepts that
we see in each chapter. And so there's
expectation maximization and gradient
descent and earlier on just some more
general things that relate to um um
perception and and the way that it's
being discussed in the textbook and
active inference elsewhere. That's all.
>> Thank you. And then Kobus, do you want
to describe what that PDF is?
Yeah, I just tried to derive equation
426 for myself and I started from both
sides.
So the the first part starts from the
minus log evidence side and finally
arrives at it being smaller or equal to
a variational free energy. And the
second part starts on the other side
uh on f and you know comes out to it
being greater or equal than than neg log
evidence
just for my own sanity sake I did that
so in case somebody else finds it
useful.
Okay, cool. I'm going to just bring that
into the just a question like we can
change what the name of the question is,
but just how is how are VF?
And then here is
here's that first one that you had.
And then here's the
another approach.
Thank you. Kus, what did you what did
you learn or take from that or what does
it mean that we can approach it those
two ways?
Well, it's just um nice to
to see everything falling in place uh
starting from either side.
Yeah, I I think the second the second
approach I think is more natural to me
at least.
Um but there's that trick where you have
to flip the numerator and denominator uh
using the negative log
um three lines from the top in the
alternative approach.
So that's kind of a trick that one has
to keep in mind. But that same trick
comes into play in the second line of
the first approach where you
where you um times by qx over qx
Yes, because the the fundamental
property of the log has to do with its
upward curving motion, but we're
interested in
um positive values on the 01 interval.
>> Yeah. And I can understand why Sanjief
did not have the luxury to be more
explicit in arriving at some of these
results. He simply didn't have the real
estate for that. But we being in an more
informal setting, um it's kind of nice
to expand on it and you know like a like
a high schooler almost just to because
there's so u many little pieces working
together. It's kind of comforting to to
uh see that you know everything is
really true if you take the patience and
the effort.
>> Yeah, that that's sort of the depth of
the material and and so many papers get
rewritten where you know a lot of the
initial material that scaffolds the rest
sort of gets breezed through a bit. um
you know we almost take it as a given
and then and then we can get to the you
know use the space the most for
presenting like the the core of what
what the paper's trying to do. And so we
we do this all the time and yeah very
much agree that's sort of what the
textbook group is supposed to allow for
is just breaking these things down
actually directly answering different
queries that that the thing we're
reading doesn't necessarily address.
Yeah, for sure.
>> Yeah. And if one writes these kinds of
papers on a daily basis, it's kind of uh
you know superfluous or unnecessary to
have this level of detail. But uh 6
months from now I I would have forgotten
how you know these results are derived.
So at least for people like me that has
to come back periodically in the future,
it's you know it's comforting to to know
that it has been captured for a high
schooler basically.
Yes, we high schoolers all and um I mean
just about the way the papers are uh
written
at a sort of like field stage analysis
or just partially Carl Fristen's
pedagogical
style. A lot of papers, even if they're
going to present a domain specific model
or whether it's like an empirical paper
or a philosophy paper or simulation
study or empirical data, you'll see like
in the beginning it'll say something
like active inference is a theory that
proposes dot dot dot because it follows
from this variational free energy and
they kind of put a lot of textbook like
material and that on one hand helps
onboard and give you that like little
bit like dropping in and reviews and
helps familiarize you if they're going
to be using some notation that's
different. Um, also though that's an
artifact of not having a textbook to
site whereas now a lot of that if people
are going to use these
reference points and derivations like in
your own papers and stuff you can just
say
in equation 4.26 26 of Nam Jooshi 2026
and just like kind of compress that part
and unpack more what's novel or
different. And this is like it's it's
good that it auto sizes to be large
because when we were discussing the the
figures it's like why is this why is the
big question about posterior density
estimation? Well, because we're going to
treat all
variables and they're updating whether
as like the omnisient modeler who has
access to all four aspects of the
particular partition internal, external,
sense, and action or whether we're
taking that more bounded agentic view
where we're only talking about belief
updating in the perception, cognition,
action like sense, internal and action.
action states or whether we're going to
restrict down even further and just
focus on the states that the agent can
control the autonomous states which are
like the internal and the action states.
So whether we have access or we're
talking about the whole particular
partition all four components or the
whole agent the whole iguana with three
components or the autonomous states with
the two components or just one of those
components we're going to treat all
kinds of variables
semantics what they mean using this
unified approach and the idea that
they're all going to relate to
information theoretic surprise
and compose into a single unified
objective function or loss function
functional.
This is really the key claim.
If we can treat different distributions
according to this bounded approximation
strategy.
If we can do variational inference on
any distribution
and we can treat perception, cognition,
action and external
in that unified variational framework.
Then the rest is just like
rearrangements and accounting and
implementation details and secondary
considerations like computational
complexity
or optimization diagnostics
or model adequacy and model selection.
Like there's still a lot more. that in a
way this um
key relationship
and the way that that key relationship
is grounded in like
the downward
um downwardly but increasing
derivative of the log
is key.
We'll look at the questions, but yeah,
go ahead. Someone
>> Yeah, I I wanted to mention this a while
back, but never got so far. I noticed
that
um just an observation
uh when the um environment is defined,
the structural form is almost always
used. However, in a case of the um
generative model, uh almost exclusively
the probabilistic uh format is used.
So um you know I would I would like to
hear some comments about that and you
know
um is something that I observed.
Yeah,
Andrew, go go go for it.
>> Yeah, just uh like
I've seen this frequently like not only
is Sanjief kind of doing that in the
textbook in places, but you know a lot
of uh research that's done in papers
that get published tend to have an
environment that's more deterministic
rather than probabilistic. not always
certainly not always but um oftentimes
or maybe there's some low degree of
stochasticity but um but you know very
minimal and I think the idea there
uh and then on the other side for the
agent keeping it probabilistic because
that's the sort of you know um
variational basian paradigm that we're
working within. So that's like kind of
the the appropriate thing I guess if you
were to like fully
adopt the active inference framework
like ideally probably the environment
you'd be modeling might also follow
probabilistic rules. Um, but I guess it
depends because when you're doing the
research, you're often times trying to
kind of isolate your experiment where uh
having a more determinist deterministic
environment kind of helps you to kind of
clarify the specific results of your
simulation that really just center upon
the agents behavior where you're sort of
controlling for uh any stoasticity from
the environment. like it can kind of
kind of muddy up the results even if
they're more realistic uh so to speak in
a concrete setting. Um they're they're
they make it more difficult to to to
kind of isolate and distinguish like
what are the specific things about the
agent uh if we know that the environment
is actually just adding a lot of
noisiness to the overall interactions
that occur. Um I hope that that actually
answers kind of the the query there that
that was what came to mind for me. Yeah.
>> Yeah. Yeah. It's um you know my take on
it is um and I think what's what's
possibly confusing here is the word
stochasticity or probabilistic
because even in the structural form you
do have um probabilistic constructs like
the um observation noise and I suppose
even um you know um the state noise XAR
XAR's noise potentially Um so so that's
one thing to kind of keep separate from
this um distinction between these uh
forms. Uh but I think personally what I
think is um possibly the reason for this
preference is that as you you know
alluded to in the case of the agent it's
more about the beliefs. It's not
strictly the structure of the generative
process and how observations are
generated out of the external states but
um the beliefs uh what the agent belief
about what's going on in the environment
and that necessitates I think the use of
the probabilistic format
>> agreed with with that like in um
equation
uh 3.1.
It it is the structural form
but um let's just see if we have the
caption.
Okay, don't have the caption but it's um
it's on page 51.
So that's the structural form, but it it
still has a a probabilistic
or a stoastgastic character.
But um it and I think that's a that's
yeah the the the
probabilistic form is more directly
amenable for example to being rendered
into a state space model.
But ultimately they're they're
interconvertible and they capture the
same information.
So
we we could develop a double
representation for all of them.
I'm not sure if there's any that are
described. Are are there any that are
described both ways like in chapter 2 or
three? I don't think I've ever come
across where there's both forums for or
one entity's description
unless I missed it somehow.
>> No. Yeah, I mean it's it's an important
educational point or or something to
look at but but again only so many um
things to explore in the book itself.
Okay,
let's um Well, so this one I think you
asked, Kobas. I mean, what do you think?
Is it fair to state that?
>> Yeah, you know, I I'm I'm pretty sure um
I'm pretty comfortable of of stating
that. Um I I somehow missed an explicit
um you know, articulation by
Sanjief that this is the definition of
variational free energy. I you know I
was expecting him to say after he starts
from the um you know that um
piece where he starts with the uh Kubak
libler uh divergence and then derives
and ends up with u vf plus log of um
evidence
um I'm trying to find the number now but
you know so at that point I u well
inside. Um, he actually has got a brace
around the the different pieces and he
indicates the uh, VFE part as such. But,
uh, it would have been comforting, you
know, for me if he outright specified
and this is the definition of
variational free energy or maybe have a
triangle above an equal sign or
something.
Um now I do realize uh VF can be put in
in various different forms but you know
it seems to me uh as as a starting point
that it would have been nice to have the
word definition used or the chief form.
>> Yeah.
for a little little um nostalgia. This
is how VFE is shown in the 2022
textbook equation 2.5
also with equal signs not with a
triangle. So not defined as such but
just like here are multiple
decompositions or partitions of them.
And that's something I tried to explore
a little bit in the fundamentals uh code
and in a few other places like
these capture different features. But
it's very interesting to think about how
it's like it's like you have the same
cake and then here's one that splits it
up this way and here's one that splits
it up this way. But but it's not like
energy is complexity. So actually
they're they're partitioning it
differently.
So it is quite interesting that we do
get these different partitions
that that analytically result in the
same total
value.
>> Yeah.
>> But they're they're they're radically
different interpretations.
And I'm I'm finding this whole
presentation in the Nam Jooshi book
right in that set of equations where
there's four different breakdowns of the
same thing to be so incredibly helpful
because as I've gone through the
literature or attempted to go through
the Fristen papers, every other paper
has like here's a new way that we're
read and it's like
and to have it all collected into one
spot and say okay these are our four
forms and these are the terminologies
and and to bring it together into a home
is just really really grounding and
centering as opposed to this dispersion
effect of every time you read a new
paper there's different notation which
starts to get maddening in itself and
then different forms for the equations
and different interpretations
which makes it really really difficult
to feel like you're catching up with the
material. So this is so very helpful and
the conversation that you gentlemen are
presenting is very useful. So thank you
folks. This is such a great uh useful
contribution that you're making to our
group here. Thank you.
>> I I definitely agree with that. Um you
know what you mentioned about the
variation of notation. Um, you know,
I've often wondered why isn't there a
ubiquitous tool available where you can
have as inputs your preference for um
let's say state uh the symbol you want
to be used for state and your preference
for um the true state and your
preference for the observation symbol
etc. And then hit a button and out comes
that paper. reformat it with your set of
symbols. Uh I I I would love to to see
to have access to a tool like that
because I it it does you know there's
such a lot of noise generated simply by
you know being used to a certain um set
of symbols and then all of a sudden
having to read a paper that uses totally
different symbols. For example, this
comparison between Berries's work at
Eintoven versus Carl Fston's work,
there's a dramatic difference in symbol
sets and it would have been nice to have
those reconciled.
>> Yeah. Well, lot to say on that. In terms
of reconciling and doing the literature
forensics, that's a topic. But in the
generalized notation notation where I
have a state space notation for models,
there's an ontology block. So then if
you want to have it in English or if you
want to call
B something different. So it just ex it
puts a little space between the the size
of the state spaces because ultimately
whatever the English or whatever natural
language you describe a variable as
isn't going to influence computationally
or procedurally what happens. But then
this gives a little bit of a space where
we can have stronger typed handling of
state space models and then assert
different onlogical labels.
And so in going forward who whoever
wants to explore GNN and and how models
can be specified there just make like I
have found that to be useful because
then we don't have to our underlying
variable
especially if we're dealing with models
that that may have dozens or or
thousands of matrices like calling it B
underscore this or even just calling
expecting the variable's name to be
loaded with semantics. like calling it
observation.
It's not very scalable or effective.
It's good like semantic programming if
you only have a few variables in scope.
But of course, if it's the thermometer's
observation, it's the room's action. So,
which one are you going to call it? And
why is that going to get loaded up into
the name of a variable? Why not just
have that one under the hood be called
some unique identifiable string? And
then it can be even multiply asserted
what it is. So we can have more like
pluralism about the naming of the
variables.
>> Yeah.
>> And and less like well does the
transition do this to that? It's like
are we in the space of the words and how
concepts connect or are we looking at
the actual state space model at which
point it doesn't matter what language
you're speaking.
>> Yeah this is really handy Daniel. Yeah,
another time we can explore that one
more. But to this to this point about
the um VF forms. So G is introduced
first
um on page 81 and then Sanjie writes we
refer to this as the G form to emphasize
the fact it contains the generative
model in the denominator.
So G per generative model of course not
to be confused with G as the expected
free energy letter which is what yeah
you would have seen in equation 2.6 from
2022 textbook. So we'll get to EF later
but just to make that point clear we're
not talking about G as EF we're talking
about something that Nam Jooshi has
introduced the G form of VF. Then we
have C, D, and E. And then I think
there's then there's F, but F is the
variable itself. So F is the is like if
we just want to talk about variational
free energy, it's F, but then we're
talking about these different forms. C
has complexity.
So that's I think what the C is for. D
is for divergence.
E is for entropy and energy.
So it's a nice little pneummonic that we
have
C D E
>> F
G. So they're all nicely
next to each other even though F is the
real
is the VF itself.
like you know apart or prior to its
decomposition. Andrew,
>> yeah, just to briefly state because
you've already said all the the main
things of like you know the these are
just different ways of sort of looking
at the same thing, different ways of
kind of breaking it apart and then you
know recognizing uh which parts we can
and cannot actually directly sort of
sort of work with. Whenever we start
putting variational free energy into uh
you know an equation or or or greater
than or equal to equality with surprisal
um I'd probably skip including f in the
in the list cuz I think that's more
confusing but uh cuz that's not even fun
if he doesn't but yeah so they're just a
g form like just on that note about the
ambiguity of syntax right it's like
Sanjie's very explicitly saying g-en
form dy-en form. So there's no there's
no f-en form or anything like that. But
uh but but then also to bring it back to
the the point of doing this is also um
you know Sanjie has inherited a fair
amount of um I don't want to call it
baggage cuz that makes it sound like a
bad thing but something like baggage
from previous publications. And so he he
is trying to to pull a lot from this
previous 2022 textbook Fristan put out
which uh Daniel showed a couple
screenshots to it um a moment ago where
uh there are different ways of breaking
down VF of EF. Um, and I think the one
of the use utilities of being able to do
that also is that whenever it comes to
energy and entropy and these other kinds
of concepts that come much more quickly
to those who uh work in in physics and
and and mathematics and looking at state
space models and energy based models or
for some other derivations where we have
terms like risk and ambiguity which come
up a lot in behavioral studies and
economics like these are different ways
ways of looking at the same thing. That
each of them kind of have their own
relationships with a variety of other uh
sort of disciplines and fields and and
ways of of sort of trying to understand
the behavior of whether it be an
organism or a person or um you know just
uh some other kind of system in general
like it's it's kind of speaks to the
interdisciplinarity
of of how active inference has been
applied. So I can never not recommend
the the 2022 textbook and especially now
that it's freely available. We have a
lot of talks from the institute on that
on YouTube previous uh textbook groups
and chapter 10 of that book just covers
the fields and applications
relationships with all of those
different things with with physics and
cybernetics and the study of emotion and
just a variety of other things. So yeah.
Yeah, it's just I think it speaks a lot
to the the diversity of how this has
been applied in other areas and I think
it kind of gives people an intermediate
uh sort of language for getting into
being able to have deeper conversations
about these things starting with what
might be more familiar to to them at
first.
>> Yeah. Something else I'd like to quickly
mention. I I attend these um meetings
with John Yan Madano
uh every other week and he mentioned
some time ago that he's actually uh
rewriting seems like the SPM
DEM module dynamic expectation
maximization
uh written by Carl Fristston uh into
into um into Python.
So, so that might be a nice um nice
thing to know um um you know uh for us
pursuing this textbook because then we
have F instance direct code translated
into Python
um and we we won't have to switch to to
MATLAB to figure out what's going on
there. and and um dynamic expectation
maximization in that module is included
what I what I basically understand as
you know active inference and
generalized filtering rather than
something centered around expectation
maximization. I think at the time that
was just a good name that Carl probably
assigned
to um basically the content we are
covering in in this textbook.
>> I I'll say briefly that I'm I'm also
working on something that's directly
translating uh SPM um as well and and
looking to get it published pretty soon
soon with a a group. Um but uh yeah,
it's no easy feat. there are a lot of
differences between Python and Mat Lab
uh in in their kind of core in terms of
random number generation etc. But um
yeah, it would be very fascinating and
uh the the brief bit that um Daniel
showed earlier about GNN, the general
notation notation project of trying to
you know kind of have this um
established ontology that we have were
better able to translate between
different terms used commonly in active
inference and elsewhere and the the
symbols that are used for each of them.
Similarly, I think the ideal would be to
be able to translate between, you know,
Python and open- source code versus
versus SPM versus RX infer and and some
of the folks that you mentioned um
earlier who all, you know, use different
notation but end up doing a lot of the
the same underlying things because I
think it would make uh things much more
accessible for those who want to start
doing experiments using active inference
to um yeah, be able to quickly get to
that But but yeah, it is it's it's uh
it's not easy. Uh SPM has been around
for for decades now. And uh you know, a
lot of it just grows out of work with um
neuroiming and signal processing. And so
a lot of things were initially centered
around continuous data and there was a
lot more expectation maximization.
That's the DEM dynamic expectation
maximization um kind of um yeah um
formula. There's also a lot of support
for DCM which is dynamic causal modeling
which is again is neuroming but all all
of those things are in SPM. Uh hopefully
going forward we'll we'll continue
making different syntheses of these
things and and make it easier to get
into them as well.
Thank you for mentioning that, Andrew.
And I'd be very interested, you know, if
if if you ever make this um uh migrated
Python code available to the outside
world, I would love to hear about it.
So, you know,
>> please
>> it will be open sourced just to say that
quickly. But yeah, I'd be happy to talk
about that more. I'd also be happy to
talk to Madano whose uh work I'm
familiar with but uh yeah in any case
for the sake of the textbook group here
>> and on that note uh I had a contract
with with a vious company and I worked a
bit with Sanjieve and um it's
interesting quite independently both of
us came up with this idea
to to make a Python library that takes
care of the uh continuous formulation
rather than this the the discrete
formulation as as is done in PIM MDP.
But what's interesting, we both came up
independently with a name uh PI active
generalized filtering. So PI AF
um but that would literally be um would
be used as a counterpart to PI MDP which
takes care of the uh discrete
formulation. But I take it uh you know
um in in your approach your Python
approach you probably take care of both
approaches not just the continuous or
not just the u discrete formulation.
>> The yeah I mean the ideal is because
hypothetically since SPM is under a GPL
open source license where you do have to
you have to reproduce the same license
but otherwise it's open source um you
can theoretically translate anything you
want. So one thing you could do is
hypothetically take the entire SPM
library and then make a Pythonic
translation of every single individual
file and then ideally then be able to
run any kind of topline simulation or
script that's within that library. So so
if for you know there are dozens of
simulations they're already available in
SPM that you can run if only you had mat
lab right. Uh so so if you could yeah
translate all the underlying functions
and have clear enough interoperability
of how it handles all the structures
underneath then you could recreate the
entire thing within Python. The trick is
you know how do you it's everything that
is specific to mat lab that is not in
python that that's the core trick not
just the syntax but the way that arrays
versus strrus are handled and all those
sorts of things. But yeah, it'd be
lovely to to really finally be able to
wed continuous and discrete uh kind of
scenarios and state spaces and and and
discreet and uh continuous time uh
models uh in in the kinds of ways that
SPM sort of already has the ability to
do. Uh and then I think arcs and fur is
kind of doing that or making some moves
towards that. But yeah, fully agree with
the the kind of priority of next steps
here uh with you. Yeah, it'd be great.
>> Yeah, this is an example from that pom
dp state space model. Here there's a um
render which prepares the executable
script
for usage in each of these frameworks.
And then there's execute which just sets
up the runtime environment and logs the
output. And then there's analysis which
analyzes and does statistics and
visualizations on the logged outputs. So
the categories of models that each of
these frameworks can do is slightly
different in principle and in practice
especially.
But um for the palm DP the these all
work. So again, just just for for the
learners out there, like I think this
whole little piece about the ontology
and the separation between the
mathematics of the variables and our
natural language assertions is like in a
given setting observation might be O if
it comes from like a behavior or or or
an agent modeling domain or it might be
Y if it's from a statistics where they
talk about X and Y, not S and O. But I
guess the part that even from the
outside or early on in your journey is
like the meaning of observation is not
um cornered by Y or by O. So those are
just like annotation tags.
Um
okay la last um question here and then
we'll just pause and the recording.
Um is it correct to say VF itself
includes expected free energy in a sense
policy selection based on costs also
serves a free energy minimization
objective? That is not correct. VF is an
instantaneous
optimization measure that is sensory
outcome oriented. We're going to get
introduced to explicit planning as
inference expected free energybased
methods in the coming chapters and those
will basically apply not to they will
not take in an observation and ask about
how bounded surprised the agent should
be. But the expected free energy has a
very different form. It's going to be a
number that describes each possible
counterfactual considered policy over a
given horizon of rollouts.
So it's going to apply to a totally
different set of things to policies that
are being considered not to observations
coming in and confusingly expected free
energy is not the expectation of
free energy.
So we will come to EF and more
forwardlooking free energy functionals
soon and yes they're they're related
but there will be more to say when we
start explicitly talking about
prospective planning as inference free
energy functionals but the VF is just
like real time unfolding it's not
explicitly looking multiple time steps
into the future
Okay, I'm going to stop the recording,
but good times. Thank you.